I think the notion that Barack Obama is
a radical is preposterous.
Uh,
Henry Louis Gates Jr who,
um,
is quoted in my book is saying that the
only radical thing,
the only truly radical thing about
Barack Obama is that he's African
American.
And I think that's true that his
politics are center center left.
They come out of the tradition of the
Democratic Party in many ways.
They're continuations of lines taken by
the Clinton administration.
You know,
look at the healthcare bill itself.
This is a more modest healthcare
building.
Many proposed by others.
He got what he could get and he
succeeded.
Um,
look at these.
So cold.
I'm radical.
Uh,
nuclear arms treaty just signed with the
Russians.
There's a lot of criticism on the right
saying,
you know,
Barack Obama is giving away our
security.
He is,
um,
he is stripping us of our capacity to
project strength in the world and to
protect ourselves.
And in fact the great leftwinger Ronald
Reagan was far more radical when it came
to nuclear arms policy.
Remember Reykjavik in the period then
Gorbachev Reagan period where those two
men were intent on reducing nuclear
stockpiles to nothing.
And here we've reduced it by a third.
I mean we,
we there the notion that Barack Obama
was somehow came out of a radical
cauldron in,
in,
in Chicago and somewhere in his desk
drawer,
um,
in the resolute desk in the Oval Office
as a copy of Mark's and grom.
She and Lennon is just obscene.
It's ridiculous.
And there are just too many elements in
the media and in politics trying to
stoke these fires for those absurd
notions to disappear.
It's very difficult to see.
I look,
I think there is a legitimate
conservative opposition as you'd expect.
Of course that's going to happen.
There's going to be a legitimate
republican opposition.
There's going to be battles.
What concerns me is not that so much.
What concerns me deeply is the outer
edges of it and the nature of the outer
edges of it.
And the way it's though the outer edges
of it are provoked by certain
politicians and certain parts of the
Internet and television and cable
television and all the rest.
And the end result of some of that kind
of ugliness can be beyond our reckoning,
really beyond our reckoning.
And,
um,
I don't want to be too alarmist of it,
but I remember for example,
in Israeli politics during gets awkward
beans time when the far right there
stirred up to such a degree that the,
that the political atmosphere in certain
quarters became quite literally
murderous.
So I think we need to be very careful
about,
uh,
lumping everybody together in its,
even the tea party movement.
I might not agree with any of it,
but the extremes of it are really
alarming.